well Blackson an interesting color
because we think of it maybe as having
once been the morning color and then
later on become the sort of the fashion
color but in fact there's always or four
centuries there's been a good black and
a bad black and blacks been about
morning and also sort of evil death
knight etc but there's also been the
sense that black was an elegant color
black dye was traditionally very
expensive so aristocrats wore black and
was ascetic you know nuns wore black but
also it was sexy you know sir
prostitutes wore black stockings in the
20s you had the little black dress and
it had a sort of a chic as a real
reaction to the bright colors that had
been in fashion a few years before then
it went out again in in the 50s again
the black was very much a fashion color
that designers like door and balenciaga
liked because it drew your attention to
the lines of the dress there were no
distractions from color or pattern you
were focusing on the silhouette of the
dress then it went out again for decades
and then the Japanese helped bring in a
new kind of sort of avant-garde black
which picked up on all of those things
the charismatic black of the elegant and
also beatnik black and the black leather
jacket the kind of charisma of evil that
was associated with black because not
just princes and priests but also
executioner's wore black it has layers
of meaning and I think that makes it
very useful as a fashion color because
you can tilt towards the elegant side or
the diabolical side you know the devil's
the Prince of Darkness but the dandies
the Black Prince of elegance I think
it's not accidental Chanel made black so
central because she was really the first
female dandy so certainly everybody
loves color but the scent color comes
and goes but black keeps coming back
with all these myriad meanings
you